I am holding something remarkably old it
is older than any human artifact older
than life on earth older than the
continents and the oceans between them
this was formed over four billion years
ago in the earliest phase of the solar
system while the planets were still
forming this rusty lump of nickel and
iron may not appear special but when it
is cut open you can see that it is
different from earthly metals this
pattern reveals metallic crystals that
can only form out in space where molten
metal can cool extremely slowly a few
degrees every million years this was
once part of a much larger object one of
millions leftover after the planets
formed we call these objects asteroids
asteroids are our oldest and most
numerous cosmic neighbors this graphic
shows near-earth asteroids orbiting
around the Sun shown in yellow and
swinging close to the Earth's orbit
shown in blue the sizes of the Earth's
Sun and asteroids have been greatly
exaggerated so you can see them clearly
teams of scientists across the globe are
searching for these objects discovering
new ones every day steadily mapping
near-earth space much of this work is
funded by NASA I think of the search for
these asteroids as a giant public works
project but instead of building a
highway
we're charting outer space building an
archive that will last for generations
these are the 1556 near-earth asteroids
discovered just last year and these are
all of the known near-earth asteroids
which at last count was thirteen
thousand seven hundred and thirty three
each one has been imaged catalogued and
had its path around the Sun determined
although it varies from a story to
asteroid the paths of most asteroids can
be predicted for dozens of years and the
paths of some asteroids can be predicted
with incredible precision for example
scientists at the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory predicted where the asteroid
Toutatis was going to be four years in
advance
to within 30 kilometers in those four
years so todd has traveled eight point
five billion kilometers that's a
fractional precision of zero point zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero four
now the reason I have this beautiful
asteroid fragment is because like all
neighbors asteroids sometimes drop by
unexpectedly three years ago today a
small asteroid exploded over the city of
Chelyabinsk Russia that object was about
19 meters across or about as big as a
convenience store objects have decides
hit the earth every 50 years or so 66
million years ago a much larger object
at the earth causing a massive
extinction 75 percent of plant and
animal species were lost including
satellites the dinosaurs that object was
about 10 kilometers across and 10
kilometers is roughly the cruising
altitude of a 747 jet so the next time
you're in an airplane snag a window seat
look out and imagine a rock so enormous
fat resting on the ground it just grazes
your wingtip it's so wide that it takes
your plane one full minute to fly past
it that's the size of the asteroid that
hit the earth it is only been within my
lifetime that asteroids have been
considered a credible threat for our
planet and since then there's been a
focused effort underway to discover and
catalog these objects I am lucky enough
to be part of this effort I'm part of a
team of scientists that use NASA's
NEOWISE telescope now neo ice was not
designed to find asteroids it was
designed to orbit the earth and look far
beyond our solar system to seek out the
coldest stars in the most luminous
galaxies and it did that very well for
its design lifetime of seven months but
today six years later it's still going
we repurposed it to discover and study
asteroids and although it's a wonderful
little space robot these days it's kind
of like a used car the cryogen that used
to refrigerated sensors is long on so we
know that it's air conditioning is
broken
Scot 920 million miles on the odometer
but it still runs great and reliably
takes a photograph of the sky every 11
seconds it's taken 23 photos since I
began speaking to you one of the reasons
NEOWISE is so valuable is that it sees
the sky in the thermal infrared that
means that instead of seeing the
sunlight that asteroids reflect nioi
sees the heat that they emit this is a
vile capability suite some asteroids are
as dark as coal and can be difficult or
impossible to spot with other telescopes
but all asteroids light or dark shine
brightly for new life astronomers are
using every technique at their disposal
to discover and study asteroids in 2010
a historic milestone was reached the
community together discovered over 90
percent of asteroids bigger than one
kilometer across objects capable of
massive destruction to earth but the
job's not done yet an object 140 metres
or bigger could decimate a medium-sized
country so far we've only found 25% of
those we must keep searching the skies
for near-earth asteroids we are the only
species able to understand calculus or
build telescopes we know how to find
these objects this is our responsibility
if we found a hazardous asteroid with
significant early warning we could nudge
it out of the way unlike earthquakes
hurricanes or volcanic eruptions an
asteroid impact can be precisely
predicted and prevented what we need to
do now is map near-earth space we must
keep searching the sky thank you
[Applause]